[Music]
foreign
[Music]
management the U.S hedge fund best known
on Wall Street for its combative
approach to shaking up sleepy corporate
boards was never meant to become the
owner of a football club when it ended
up taking over AC Milan one of the most
storied teams in Italy about five years
ago it happened by accident
the hard-nosed investor had initially
decided to finance the audacious 2017
bid of a little-known Chinese
businessman Lee Yong Huang to buy AC
Milan from former Italian Prime Minister
Sylvia Berlusconi however Lee's
ownership proved brief as it defaulted
in 2018 giving Elliot control of the
club what Elliot took over was a fallen
star of European football AC Milan Was a
Serial winner of Europe's top tournament
in the 1990s and 2000s and won scores of
Italy's Syria titles during that period
thanks to the talent of the likes of
Marco rambasten George Weir Andrea Pirlo
and Paolo Maldini to name a few
but in the Years leading up to the
Takeover the club had stopped performing
on the pitch a failure that weighed on
its revenues when we took over it was a
totally disastrous situation one of
Elliot's top lieutenants confessed to
get the club back in shape it hired Ivan
gazidis from Arsenal as chief executive
with a mission to repair the club's
finances while moldini was promoted to
football director
with a goal to cut the squad's budget by
ditching big earners and bringing in
younger cheaper players
the only controversial exception to that
formula was bringing in Zlatan
Ibrahimovic one of the finest
Centerfolds of his generation
however the 40 year old was decisive in
igniting a Revival of the club's fortune
on and off the pitch
first bring the club back into the
Champions League at the end of the 2021
season and finally winning the Seria
title in 2022
the turnaround has allowed Elliot to
finally monetize its investment as it
agreed to sell the club for a record 1.2
billion euros to Jerry cardinales
private Equity Group Redbird
now it will be up to cardinalale to add
further major titles and take the club
to the next level
it will do so with the support of Elliot
which is partially financing the
acquisition and will retain board seats
at the club as well as providing key
assistance in either revamping the
club's historic stadium in sincero or
building a new one elsewhere
[Music]